Doug Gottlieb kind enough to join us on
loan from Fox Sports I what is important
at the NBA combine Doug who you are you
know you know like the measurables
aren't terribly important for some guys
but you know if you're if you come
across as a guy who's not particularly
long you know like take Trey young for
example right so he's he's the new Steph
Curry but he's not as tall and not as
long and my guess would be not quite as
as athletic so he's a just slightly
shorter version of the guy we've seen
when two MVPs and you gotta kind of
gotta take the leap you know whereas a
Collin Sexton who's up about the same
height maybe even a little bit smaller
he's got longer arms you have to kind of
try and yet to formulate in your mind
what that looks like two three four
years down the road you know Moe Bombo
we do as a freak of nature in terms of
his length and athleticism I think
forgot like Grayson Allen
everybody knows Grayson Allen can really
jump but the fact that he I think he had
the best lateral agility score that's
really important because you guys
remember Chase Budinger from Arizona
yeah he's a great great volleyball
player he could jump but like being yeah
but being jumped like that's not really
that as important as lateral quickness
in the NBA and for Grayson if he's gonna
play in the NBA he's gonna be a - and
that's a - you got to be able to you
guys how do you move laterally and he
said he's a tricky and giving Genzo a
tremendous athletes not just vertically
but laterally so any different things
matter different people I wish more guys
more the top guys would play like I
don't know basketball players play
basketball I kind of thought that's the
whole deal but those are the things that
matter it's very much taste dependent
yeah I'm just trying to figure this out
and I know that you know the motherships
trying to make something out of the NBA
combine but I'm just trying to figure
out what I gleaned from this where I go
okay that's important I think height I
think the wingspan is important too
you know I like that with these guys
depending on the position but it feels
like the game is you know we're moving
towards the longer player the perimeter
player the taller guy who can shoot
threes so that's you know if marquel
folds
you know that's the surprising part
Markel folds goes number one when you
look at the NBA and the NBA the future
of it is not marquel folds it's more
Jason Tatum yeah but it is about can you
have a guard that can go down hill and
they could make plays from south and for
others and like look last year I joined
you and I told you Jason Tatum was the
most ready to play did I think you'd be
this good as impactful no it should be
pointed out I don't think he would be
this good or this impactful and he would
not gotten hurt
right like that actually end up
benefiting him because now the sudden he
had to play much you know greater
minutes earlier on his career so look
you're right in that the NBA is working
the way of the hybrid solar and that's
where Danny Ainge and his team they were
ahead of everybody else what last year
when they reformulate the roster they
had a bunch of little guards and they
got rid of you know several guards to
get these hybrid forwards that is the
way the leaks working but it also is
working with the non-traditional point
guard taneous school and folks still has
that ability I will see if he gets his
jump shot back we'll see how his body
develops but you know I guys who were
you know part of draft rooms and in
those workouts and I said look he's far
away the best guard last year it's a
reason that he he was so well sought
after and and maybe the other part to
the draft is we're talking there's two
great rookies out of the strap there's a
lot of rookies that weren't very good
out of the draft last year and I kind of
feel like we're gonna end up working
that way with this draft you know
Michael Porter juniors a guy who you
know some think is gonna you know creep
in the top three or top four even though
he barely played at Missouri cuz the
back injury he's a he's got hybrid
forward now you know when you get past
those those top five or six guys maybe
eight guys this is not a deep that deep
a draft we're in the 20s you're gonna
get a guy who's gonna be a rotation guy
remember how badly Kevin Durant
performed at the combine and he couldn't
bench 185 pounds and then people go boy
how is he going to survive in the NBA
does it really matter
you know I thought it mattered at at
that point a little bit but yeah on the
other hand he's also simply three yeah
you know again it's it's case dependent
is it matter to him no but it depends on
who you are right like if you're I need
to go back to tre young but the way
everybody plays in the NBA now is you
switch everything and who's he gonna
switch in guard and like look that's the
problem that the Cavs have that's
honestly I know you're talking about
other LS do you talk about Steph Curry
whether or not he's hurt I mean I'd have
to think it's a combination of he's
still a little dinged up and it's not
necessarily dinged up it's you can't go
from rehabbing to playing the playoffs
level of intensity so great that you're
just you know you're always you're
always trying to kind of play catch-up
but you know the biggest thing is they
just keep going at him defensively and
that wears you down if you're a if
you're a guard who's going to be six
feet tall and play in the NBA you got to
be tougher than a $2 steak you know
there's a there's a reason that that the
delis of the world can last there's a
reason you got to be a tough sucker and
I don't know if we have that and if you
show that you're not strong it shows one
you have to add strength but can you add
that strength and keep your jump shot
that's a big question we're talking to
Doug Gottlieb prompt sports joining us
if you had the top pick in the draft who
you take it I'm taking Marvin Bagley now
I understand that you have other hybrid
forwards with the Phoenix Suns I think
he's the best prospect and you talked
about the way the NBA is going
I know I know DeAndre is a freak of
nature and he's his body looks I mean he
looks like the after picture right Bamba
looks like the before he looks like the
after but you know centers its centers
in the NFL
centers in the NBA or like middle
linebackers in the NFL night or bloody
backs maybe it's a glamour position but
is it absolutely going to help you you
have to have one to win a championship
now the one caveat I would put on that
Dan is the Phoenix Suns are horrific
defensively and they need somebody to
protect the rim but that's not he's not
really a true natural shot blocker he
does a little bit of everything well I
would go with bag repeat a bag to play
two or maybe three positions in the NBA
he should be eventually able to guard at
least two positions in the NBA I don't
think you'll ever play you know like a
rim protecting
but if you get if you can get Chris Bosh
you take them and I think that's that's
what what badly at worst when maybe at
worse at best probably becomes a really
productive Chris Bosh I'm more of a
Bagley guy who everybody's talking about
Gajic and talking about Aydin I would
even consider Collin Sexton with the
right team just because I think he has a
chance to be a dynamic lead guard that
can guard create shots and his tough
tough as hell those are the guys that I
but I'd go it back with yeah you can't
take Sexton number one probably not but
I remember back when you and I were at
the mothership and someone Andrew Bogut
went number one overall yeah okay
and I think Marvin Williams went to
overall and three and four
I forget the year were Deron Williams
and Chris Paul and I wrote a piece for
USP not calm and I was like look those
guys are good and they're big and
whatever but the league is about it it's
about guys that can create shots
themselves guys create jobs for others
and I still think that's more important
and so I understand that that Aten as
the center can play both ends report in
particular you can she can shoot out to
college three now eventually he'll be
shooting pro series but I I do think you
know as good as Clint capela is at some
point he becomes fairly useless because
you got them they got to go PJ Tucker is
like you're undersized center you know
you're talking about draymond Green is
your Center for the for the Golden State
Warriors nobody scores their back to the
basket now the only other part that is
you and I have talked about this is with
the Joyland beads of the world with that
with the developing big guys to that
does it come back around that you have
to have a big guy to compete but to this
point I would go with the hybrid forward
which is where we discard in a Marvin
Bagley first I would go with a lead
guard second and I would go with a
center third you know position dependent
the problem is that Ayden is a
remarkable prospect he'd played
obviously the Arizona the owner is an
Arizona alum and it feels like the team
needs a center even with Dragon bender
really improving at the NBA good thanks
for calling in have a good weekend we
appreciate it
I do I actually agree with McLovin on
this thing though by the way I think
McLovin he's got his big board he's got
that
you want that this is the first Dan you
didn't know I had a big board I did not
I know you had a small board yeah he is
his board is quite big a lot of people
talk about how biggest board is actually
uncomfortable how well I guess you and
great minds think alike doc you and you
and McLovin
there we go me and McLovin on an island
together Thank You doc guts Doug
Gottlieb for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]